let's get frisky that's a double
entendre actually no it is only a single
entendre because this video is all about
be announcing my participation in this
list it's time for the third annual you
don't know what the [ __ ] that is I
assumed this is just sponsored by
Friskies the cat food company and it is
an award show to celebrate the most
hilarious epic interesting funny blah
blah blah more adjectives cats on the
Internet I'm in a different state right
now so this is the closest headgear I
could get to looking like cat ears just
pretend that this is a caddie r head
this isn't just for cats that are
already famous it's for your cat to
become famous think of it like the voice
for cats so this is how the award show
works this year there are the grand
masters of ceremony the fine brothers to
cool cats and then there are four
categories cat or boys there are four
genres of cat videos that this is asking
for you to submit to and each genre has
its own captain and I'm the captain of
the funny comedy genre what does that
mean excellent question it means that
you have an opportunity to go to the
first used ya home and submit your funny
cat video under my category because
here's the thing all the category heads
are competing and I don't think any of
those category heads got anything on my
head where right now
wow that felt right cats feel very
self-serving the only thing they say is
me ow if you think that your cat is
really funny and you have the cat on
camera being funny submit that video to
your first piece home under the category
funny or comedy or hilariousness
whatever the funny one is if you don't
have a cat or a video of a cat being
funny that's okay t you're not a freak
you can still go to first gusta home and
vote for your favorite cat video in any
specific category all of the submissions
will get narrowed down to 12 finalists
and then the audience will vote on those
12 finalists to figure out who is the
winner and the video that wins the
audience vote gets this amount of money
you could buy so many cats with that
money but more than that the video that
wins the category that it's in the
captain of that category gets to give
ten thousand dollars to their animal
charity of choice think of how many
casinos all those little animals could
go to so to summarize the fish used are
coming very soon and you can now go to
the first Easter home and submit your
cat video to possibly win mmm cash money
that's the only reason to get a pet is
to make them internet famous and profit
off of them in a financial way also
please please alania serious for a
second please don't put your cat in
danger it's one thing to watch america's
funniest home videos and watch a guy
like trip over a lawnmower or try and
like rope swing into a lake and hit a
tree please don't make your cat do that
just be smart I know you guys there but
I don't know
look these are the little cat ears look
if they're not there no that just looks
like I'm from Russia